you have this movie based on the machine
okay Memorial Day Weekend Memorial Day
week you get to cast the movie
your wife and you have some Elite milk
as your wife so
[Music]
how did she feel about what you wish she
looked like oh no no no no no oh no
that's not even that's not even the good
question okay go go go go go go I did
not get to pick my wife wait she picked
it Leanne picked her
shout out to Stephanie Leanne loved her
she goes that's that's me and I went
really she goes yup she goes as a matter
of fact I want to get on the phone with
her what was she eating in that in that
uh audition because those look good
they're good they're called flip sides
because I'm getting flip sides I like
that woman flip side to the chocolate
covered pretzels no no the pretzel on
one side cracker on the other hand my
full house is pretty [__] it's a new
hybrid they've come up with recently
yeah they're [__] awesome yeah so
then Bird's only Cutting Edge of snacks
yeah this is a good story
the best part is
um I didn't realize I had a kissing
scene
oh did you not I swear to God I swear to
God I swear to God I swear to God they
just sprung it up on me my wife's in
Serbia okay she comes out for the first
like week of shooting
and we do the kissing scene and I find
out that night I'm gonna go I have a I'm
kissing her tomorrow on the angers he
didn't know that I said well I didn't
read the [__] script like I mean I
read it but I didn't really
read the action part one of the couple
other guys wrote it I just punched it up
I don't read the action part I just read
the words punch it up bad news she goes
yeah you have a kissing scene and I was
like yeah oh my God like what do I do
she's like you're gonna kiss her so I
went over dude you're a [__] genius
and I uh I had not kissed another woman
in 20 years yeah
and then you let your wife pick the
woman that you got to cheat on her with
and I'll tell you right now my wife's
got great taste
no but I had to kiss this woman did you
get erect did you get a bonus I wouldn't
say I got my yeah whatever you know a
little Chub down I'll tell you right now
I'll tell you right now I can understand
do you run that scene a few times before
you recorded like this is how bad of an
actor I am we had to do a pickup for
Mark Hamill where uh he had to say his
lines and then he's doing his type Luke
Skywalker plays his [__] Dad it's
insane yeah I'm in a different wardrobe
I'm in different wardrobe than the scene
should take we're just doing this pickup
real quick and then Marx's line and then
we kiss and off camera I kissed her and
everyone's like what the [__] are you
doing and I went and I was like I'm
getting I'm doing the scene and they're
like
no one's still
but you went for it yes
is that not what we're supposed to do
where were your hands when you kiss her
uh or her back on her back but do you
slide
the kids said I had to knock her off her
feet oh
I'm not a good kisser but uh but yeah it
was crazy it was it was bizarre and then
that night my wife like gets in bed and
she was like hey you wanna kiss a little
faithful I was like beat a scissor lip
kissing her like licking an envelope
eyes open dude I'm a bad kisser yeah is
that why you don't cheat because you're
just bad at it yeah well I'm bad at sex
it's the same reason like my wife
doesn't sing karaoke she can't [__]
sing the reason I don't [__] chicks on
the road is because I can't [__] dude
same two same dog I'm glad I'm glad I
can't [__] wait how do you know you
can't [__] because I've done it I've
done it I've been there every time and
you're comparing yourself to like
professionals no I'm comparing myself to
uh to does your wife I've gotten from
the women I've had sex with okay let's
go on to these notes because this is fun
all right
yeah yeah the best note are you gonna
put it in and you thought it was in I
thought I'd already had an orgasm
in the bed oh
I lost my virginity that's how two pumps
done she says are you gonna put it in my
dick's between her butt cheek in the bed
I didn't even need a person there I
could have done it myself and I was like
[__] that's the first time I lost my
virginity yeah yeah okay but that could
just be a mix-up that's just one okay
lose your virginity yeah yeah you
misplaced your virginity for a couple of
minutes
can you tell us the second time second
time was uh right after it when I went
in with a compromised condom
I
blowload condoms done she says are you
gonna put it in I'm like oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah and that's when I lost my
virginity when I or in a it's like
imagine if I went let's go for a hike I
go but first let's open a river and get
our socks real quick you had to cut them
on and then came between the bed sheets
yeah yeah yeah yeah filled up the condom
I thought it was two different no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no it's
the same [__] night all in one night
dude I I was that is how I'm introduced
to sex in my [__] life I'm like [__]
this I didn't [__] again for like a
couple years I was like yeah because I
was like I gotta [__] figure this
[__] out yeah do some reflection yeah
and then I the next time I had sex
I was in college and uh and I jerked off
before I had sex and I was like and then
and yeah and then I was I was good but I
guess I'm still I've always been fast
like really fast like oh so it's not
your skill in bed in some time I come
fast yes yes yes
I have so many jokes about it uh I have
one uh [__] means like a rodeo six
seconds and then I hop off my buddy
comes dressed like a clown distractor
um
true story blue load really quick and
then I went I think someone's breaking
into my house
yeah I had an orgasm this one's in
Razzle Dazzle right now I don't orgasm
so fast one time Leanne laughed at me
laughed and said [__] I don't think you
could have gotten AIDS from that
yes I am [__] fast bro so like I
have you ever satisfied your wife you
think yeah no no I give her an orgasm
but not with my dick from what do you do
oral sex oral I've never are you nice at
Oral
yeah you're really good aren't you yeah
yeah I really am I really are I gotta be
honest with you if I was if I wasn't
gonna cheat on my wife
this is the worst way to cheat you don't
even come and you just want to make a
girl feel good that wasn't your wife
piece of [__] he's a people pleaser all
right dude
I remember Nikki Glazer I think said
something to me one time I'm I forget
she goes just so you know not all chicks
like the exact same oral sex and in my
head I was like oh
for real yeah because I know I mean I'm
really good at oral sex yeah oh yeah the
other day the other day the other day I
gave her an orgasm and like a gangster
walked out of the room while it was
still happening just like strutted my
way out she's just like ah what and I
just got up and walked out I was like
that's how it's done like a fade away
three like just like Curry
you just walked away while I was still
[__] in there
yeah yeah it's so weird to hear sex
stories about your wife it is it's kind
of well yeah I guess I'm because you
know what I mean yeah